why are you out I with if Jake Paul
fights Fury okay because I don't think
I don't think a boxing Community has set
Jacob uh to very large extents I mean
they already did this once they told him
go fight Fury now they didn't want to
see the fight and they full well knew
that if he went and had the fight they
were going to take the credit from him
and say oh this guy's never fine but in
the top 10 and he's not a real boxer and
Fury's got a combined record all of his
opponents combined I can't remember but
it's something like nine wins against
125 losses it was absolutely insane if
you go and take the six guys that he
bought that's well and good but the
community told Jake to do the fight
they're telling him this is the one
we'll get behind let's encourage it the
old man's uh character his brother
Tyson's the most respected guy and
they're just setting him up for failure
and I don't really feel like coming and
telling the audience to watch this fight
that I don't think fumbles is going to
show up to and moreover it turns out uh
that it's going to be held in Saudi
Arabia so there will be the money for
those guys are gonna throw down the yeah
the cash and now it's a lot more likely
than if he was going to come over and do
it at Madison Square Garden on his own
but you know I I'm not comfortable
believing it's gonna happen I don't
think the guy wants to box him you think
they can even sell out Madison Square
Garden I know that was Daniel white beef
of like he's like yeah it's hard to put
on a fight it is especially that MSG
you're talking about Tommy Fury yeah and
that's the problem I don't think Tommy
and Jake Paul could sell the guard now
because don't forget they've done a
million dollars and it was filling up
pretty nicely and uh they had to refund
all the tickets because because Tommy
didn't get on the plane and come do it
so I don't think you could come and burn
that same Market twice
what about t wood were you were you
shocked when he got knocked out the way
he did I was shocked and it was a hard
hit yes it was the hardest hit I've ever
seen in boxing yeah and then face down
with the butt wipes promos
he he's really good Jake Paul and that
pains people to admit I don't know why
but that really people did not want to
give him or his brother credit for being
tough guys but they are they were tough
guys in high school they were all state
wrestlers in Ohio which is a very
competitive State
um and they got into the boxing and they
really shouldn't have had enough time to
be this good even though they're
training twice a day every day four
years isn't that long to be as good as
he is to go out there and beat Anderson
Silva for goodness sakes his brother
went the distance with Floyd I don't
care about that size difference you went
you went 30 minutes with Floyd good job
um if for some reason people don't want
to say that about him but see I saw what
you saw he hit him hard he hit T wood
hard he took hard shots in the meanwhile
he's got very good faints people people
don't quite understand how important a
faint is but you can't just get it
you're not born with it sometimes you're
born with power but you're not born with
the ability to to do a movement get the
other guy to it's like a chess move
right that's right and so you know to
watch him go out and do that you know
while being tired while being attacked
that's it though yeah I know you're
fooling around but that's what it is
my I went to high school with guys that
were jerks that would do that and go two
for flinch for some reason I gotta punch
you in the shoulder but that's a real
thing if you can get a guy flinched you
get he went to Flinch and freeze up so
you can come in and land that hook man
Jake deserves credit they
gave it to him I could be wrong but
didn't Jake just uh reach out to Nate
Diaz to say signed with pfl which is
another MMA organization and that's like
the biggest curveball of all like now
Jake Paul's committed to fighting MMA
and he challenged Nate Diaz to uh two
fights one MMA one boxing yeah yeah yeah
which is an interesting thing do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude